this is a Fox News Alert it is election
night in many states and we already have
a race to call in the state of Florida
big show ahead but first chief national
correspondent Edie Henry is live for us
in Miami tonight Edie
Tucker good to see you the polls have
just closed here in the Sunshine State
and Fox News is projecting that
congressman Ron de Santos is going to
win the Republican primary for governor
this is a big race the Trump factor
front and center we are projecting
tonight that he will beat former
congressman Adam Putnam he's currently
the state agriculture commissioner
here's the bottom line back in June when
Fox News had a big debate between these
two Republican contenders De Santis was
trailing big time double digits and then
within days President Trump
endorsed DeSantis we then saw him take a
double-digit lead in recent days that
had closed a bit Putnam had out raised
him in the money Department he had
knocked on hundreds of thousands of
doors there had been some expectation
here on the ground in Florida maybe
Putnam could pull this out but we are
projecting just the opposite Ronda
Santa's a key ally of President Trump is
going to win this Republican a
nomination primary battle for the
gubernatorial race there's three big
candidates on the Democratic side that
we're not ready to call it still too
close to call we'll be back later this
hour as more results come in doctor
amazing decisive ed Henry thanks thanks
a lot good to see you